[Música]
ay
se erige frente al mediterráneo en la
bahía de los ángeles
en misa el negresco destaca majestuosa
mente sobre el paseo de los ingleses
empujar la puerta de esta joya de la
bella época no es entrar simplemente en
un hotel de lujo
[Música]
desde el primer piso hasta el quinto las
obras de arte están por todas partes
techos de vidrio eiffel arañas baccarat
impresionante enana de niki de saint
phalle y la atracción principal de la
colección el retrato oficial de luís 14
[Música]
cerca de 6000 obras expuestas y 124
habitaciones en total
numerosas personas hacen funcionar este
hotel inclasificable
170 en total el servicio debe ser
impecable las 5 estrellas lo obligan en
los pisos el personal está activo desde
la mañana hasta la noche camarera
servicio si no responden se puede entrar
para evitar las malas sorpresas
exactamente cada camarera está encargada
de limpiar 11 habitaciones al día el
tiempo está contado 40 minutos por
habitación más o menos es suficiente o
transcurre rápido hay que trabajar
rápido
el uniforme de las camareras es negro y
blanco azul blanco y rojo el de los
conserjes
me falta el último toque
aquí se cultiva la imagen anticuada de
la gente de casa burguesa
la elegancia es clase a la francesa lo
llamo mi traje de luz entramos en escena
uno se pone en su lindo traje y estamos
listos para trabajar durante el día
y el terreno de juego de olivia macrón
bienvenido al negresco es detrás de este
mostrador
me ocupo de ello y le entregó la tarjeta
fieles a supuestos varios son los
empleados con mucha antigüedad
marc tiene el rejón yo aquí se aproximó
más positivos
obtuve la gran medalla de oro de los 40
años
ingresó al negresco a los 17 años para
un trabajo de temporada y nunca abandonó
el lugar conoció a la última propietaria
del hotel una jefa a la antigua
a veces me llamaba todo está bien tenía
carácter era autoritaria a veces cuando
tenía algo en la cabeza no se le salía
hacía lo que quería la jefa era la jefa
de la propietaria jean ayer falleció en
esta mujer de negocios distinta a todas
había comprado el palace en
1957 con un objetivo devolverle al
negresco su brillo de antaño
en aquella época ha supervisado a las
obras compraba muebles de época y obras
de arte su credo era poner de relieve el
saber as el francés
también hicieron sesión con el príncipe
donde cubrió mi novio no es que yo
tropas ayer rival sé que él desde es la
representación peruana de la font se
dijeron
yang oye le dio así al negresco un alma
una marca de fábrica que hoy en día aún
atrae visitantes del mundo entero pero
también locales como este habitante de
niza que siempre ha sentido pasión por
el palacio creció una cuadra del cinco
estrellas la fastuosidad del hotel sólo
las conocía a través de anécdotas
contadas por sus amigos empleados del
palacio entonces venir a negresco es más
que un sueño
es algo importante para un habitante de
niza poder entrar al negresco y comer
vivir beber algo
quiere decir que uno tuvo éxito en su
vida para venir a comer en el regreso
al lugar al que vienen a comer todos los
grandes de este mundo
cada noche los clientes pueden descubrir
las nuevas creaciones imaginadas por el
chef del palace
es el cual empero callado de mojama y
ternura un coliflor puede ser un plato
dos estrellas con coliflor cualquier
producto mientras sea bien tratado
respetado
un col ahumado en madera de haya el
detalle que hace la diferencia
ese grupo felicidades en
un restaurante con estrellas
[Música]
los gastrónomos aprecian también el
servicio a la francesa y sus jefes de
comedor enfocados en el detalle sabíamos
que sería una velada maravillosa y vamos
a estar en un entorno excepcional con un
servicio excepcional entonces todo hace
parte de la misma foto
las últimas voluntades de la propietaria
desaparecida son claras en negresco debe
seguir siendo uno de los únicos para las
franceses totalmente independiente
i